jean marc sylvestre journalistes et de
taurian east economic sur rt france
bonsoir jean marc sylvestre merci d'être
avec nous
les prévisions du fmi un récession
mondiale historique recul de 3% on l'a
vu rebond de 5,8 pour cent
toujours selon le fmi l'année prochaine
c'est quand même encourageant ou
l'économiste que vous êtes est très
inquiet dans l'économie ce que je suis
weeds est inquiet et il est inquiet
notamment des répercussions sociales
parce que derrière une crise économique
et financière il ya évidemment des
répercussions sociales parce qu'il ya
des messieurs aussi inquiets des
répercussions de la crise sanitaire tout
ça n'est pas réglé mais mais c'est vrai
que en termes purement théorique
si l'on regarde ce qui s'est passé la
situation va être catastrophique
cc g mais l'appareil de production ne
sera pas détruit
donc on peut comme les organisations
internationales penser que parce que
l'appareil de production n'a pas été
détruit on assiste à un rebond
l'année suivante il va falloir passer
l'année et il va encore falloir gérer ce
déconfinement qui l'état de confinement
général non je pense que c'est une crise
qui est totalement inédite
on n'a jamais eu ça dans l'histoire
qu'on remonte très loin dans l'histoire
il n'y a pas eu de crise qu'ils soient
mondiale et qui soit aussi profonde que
cette si les grandes les guerres les
deux guerres mondiales ont fait des
dégâts considérables mais pas en termes
papa au niveau purement économique comme
celle ci est tant au niveau mondial pas
dans tous les hémisphères s'étaient
concentrés à l'espace européen la crise
de 1929 n'a pas eu cette ampleur là la
crise de 2008
ben non plus et on a su gérer le
redressement ce type est très troublant
dans cette affaire est née et bruno le
maire le le sens bien c'est que on n'est
pas sûr de la visibilité en matière de
déconfinement mais pas seulement france
a partout ailleurs on ne sait pas ce qui
peut se passer
et tant que nous aurons cette épée de
damoclès sur la tête
c'est à dire la présence d'un virus dont
on ne connaît pas l'identité dont ne
sait pas exactement par où il va sans
traitement sans vaccin est bien le
rapport de confier
des acteurs de l'économie ne pourra pas
être restaurée et c'est en confiance et
bien vous n'avez pas d'activité si le
cours sauf si le déconfinement dure
encore quelques mois ça va pouvoir être
effectivement draper si on s'en tient à
la fin mai ou avant l'été voit dans la
plupart des pays développés
c'est vrai qu'on peut espérer l'année
prochaine mais l'année prochaine
mais entre temps on aura quand même de
sacrés factures arrivent alors
effectivement jean marc sylvestre vous
ai dit ok des scénarios le fmi lui aussi
on évoque trois alternatives une
pandémie non prises non maîtrisée à la
fin du mois de juin ils seront
d'épidémie survenue en 2001 terme est
plus légère une troisième c'est la
combinaison des mauvaises nouvelles un
prolongement de la paralysie et du
confinement au second semestre suivie
d'une seconde et puis les miens
survenant en 2021
voilà je vous demande pas de le lire
dans la boule de cristal mais vous
quelle est la liste que vous privilégiez
jean marc sylvestre
je pense que je pense que la piste que
je voudrais privilégiées on peut on peut
évidemment imaginer tous et le fmi à un
scénario qui est un scénario de la fin
du monde
donc on peut aussi privilégier un
scénario fondé sur les scientifiques
savoir que tous les laboratoires
aujourd'hui on en trouve sur le pied de
guerre
ils travaillent ils travaillent à des
traitements on en sait quelque chose
avec des débats qui sont parfois agités
dans la communauté scientifique mais ces
débats existent et ils sont ils sont de
bonne de bonne tenue
et puis la découverte d'un vaccin
on va forcément avoir des solutions
médicales sanitaire vers l'avant la fin
de cette année d'abord les tests ensuite
des traitements une fois qu'on aura les
tests on sera qui est malade et ceux qui
ne le sont pas on sera ceux qui sont
porteurs d'anticorps et ceux qui ne sont
pas porteurs d'anticorps vous rendez
compte on aura fait un toit un chemin
énorme pour vous restaurer cette
confiance
et puis non seulement un vaccin à
l'institut pasteur nous laisse penser
qu'on aura un cadeau de noël ce sera le
pacs un antivirus je moi ce confiance
dans l'intelligence des scientifiques
parce que c'est vraiment sur eux qu'il
faut se fonder premier point deuxième
point il y à une ré
action naturelle des agents économiques
pour pouvoir se redresser
on a besoin de travailler on a besoin de
financer ses progrès on a besoin de
consommer il ya quand même un certain
nombre de lieux en chine où on
s'aperçoit la consommation a repris là
quelques industriels qu'il me le dise et
que c'est que c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas complètement étouffé même s'il ya
encore des risques
faut il va falloir faire attention
quoique la période la plus difficile qui
va l'être qui va venir si la période qui
guide d'aidé six mois prochain le
déconfinement justement jean marc
sylvestre venez moelleux déconfinement
vous en parliez tout à l'heure on a vu
que certains pays favorisés plus que
d'autres peut-être l'économie donald
trump aimerait bien puisqu'il pousse
pour des confiné dès le 1er mai la suède
en europe a fait ce choix dès le départ
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas finalement
une solution uniforme pour tous les les
pays du mouron qu'on aille dans le même
sens dont je pense pas je pense pas
anormale et illégitime que chaque pays
en fonction de sa culture en fonction si
structures politiques sont ses habitudes
son éducation aussi son niveau de
développement puissent développer son
propre modèle mais je dois dire que le
bureau le le job des politiques
aujourd'hui est absolument épouvantable
parce que ils doivent en permanence
gérer deux objectifs qui sont un peu
contradictoire le premier objectif c'est
d'assurer la sécurité sanitaire et la
sécurité sanitaire nous demandent de
chine vous si vous voulez du quelque
part d'étouffer un peu l'activité
humaine il faut rester chez soi faux
seins et puis le deuxième objectif c'est
de maintenir en activité les mécanismes
de production on voit bien que c'est
contradictoire et on voit bien que même
dans les mesures qu'a donnée macro il
est partagé
c'est un compromis entre la nécessité de
garantir la sécurité sanitaire et aussi
l'obligation qu'il a de ne pas tuer la
machine économique par un confinement
trop prononcé on le voit bien par
exemple sur l'école on allait les
restaurateurs ont le droit vous les
entendiez tout à l'heure de se demander
pourquoi on va autoriser les enfants à
retourner à l'école alors qu on
n'autorisera pas les clients à venir au
restaurant
bon eh eh bien c'est c'est un problème d
de déconner
micky qui viala bon ça c'est la page la
part de déconfite de confinement mais
compliqué elle va compliquer parce que
le monde d'après sera pas forcément le
même que celui d'avant même s'il n'est
pas chambouler un justement jean marc
sylvestre le monde d'après ça sera ma
dernière question emmanuel macron qui
atteint une refondation
il n'a pas changé son discours emmanuel
macron il parle d'indépendance
financière notamment dans les milieux
industriels technologiques sanitaires
mais aussi agricole ça ne vous a pas
échappé c'est un vrai changement de
stratégie pour le président thein c'est
un bon c'est pas forcément un vrai
changement de stratégie pour ma part
c'est un changement de discours
d'analysé de présentation il change sa
pédagogie mais il tient compte des faits
est un pragmatique il sait très bien que
la digitalisation va s'accélérer cette
crise du virus du coronavirus et bien
fait un boulevard pour toute la
digitalisation on le voit bien le
télétravail et puis les lalala
l'utilisation des progrès technologiques
et cédera donc c'est absolument
indispensable la deuxième chose c'est
que c'est vrai on va sans doute
relocaliser un certain nombre
d'activités
d'une part pour tenir compte des
contraintes qui peuvent exister en
matière justement de risque sanitaire
mais également d' indépendance en
matière de fourniture de essentiel d'un
certain nombre de choses et puis je
crois que la troisième chose mais ça ça
va être très important c'est qu'il va
faire qu'on s'organise nous mêmes
regardez je reviens sur vos
restaurateurs un restaurant qui oki qui
servait tous les soirs 80 couverts
il ne pourra plus servir 80 couverts
dans l'avenir c'est à dire dans l'année
qui vient ou peut-être dans les besoins
il faudra qu'ils organisent de la
distanciation sociale la distanciation
social c'est quoi eh bien il passera de
80 à 40 couverts alors il va falloir
quand même qu'ils s'organisent son
modèle économique est totalement
différent donc ça va quand même demandé
un énorme changement il y compris
d'ailleurs dans les méthodes de
gouvernement et j'ai trouvé que le
président macron avec cette honnêteté
dingue
il faudra que tout le monde change y
compris moi même merci jean marc
sylvestre d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france confiné vous aussi
merci à vous